ich hatte natürlich die verantwortlichen
spekulanten ich war mir darüber im
klaren was falsch ist er im angriff von
gräfin der sowjetunion oder ungarn
kommen sollten wir eigentlich eine sehr
geringe überlebenschancen hatten dass
wir diesen auftrag den wir hatten
erfüllten nämlich die grenze zu sichern
und auch zu verteidigen bedarf keiner
weiteren erwähnung
wenn ich von mir aus sagen kann die
haltung aller angehörigen mehrerer pany
kann ich nur mit hübschen ropers wegen
dem man muss sich das einmal in unserer
zeit des jahres 2006 vorstellen was ich
für junge männer von 18 bis 20 jahre
bedeuten würde
innerhalb von stunden mit der tatsache
konfrontiert zu werden dass sie ihr
leben in den letzten stunden verlieren
können
noch dazu über meinen sie wohl den
offizier beruf anstreben
aber sie waren auch junge männer die
abnehm wesentlichen vielleicht den
vollen ernst dass beruflicher gar nicht
kennengelernt dann konnten ist damit
kämen aber ich habe traut mehrmals schon
verwiesen
sie haben sich hervorragend gehalten und
bis an mein lebensende
ich habe viele führungsaufgaben im
bundesheer vollführt am schluss eine
division geführt werde ich das verhalten
dieser nella
niemals fertig